tu was du tun musst ok meine lieben
freunde kommen der sich bereit für das
er ist du bist nach oben weil ich glaube
weg nach oben erscheint ihr gleich das
items oder was auch immer
monument complete oje das passiert was
passiert was ist passiert ich habe
nichts gehört
hallöchen freuen und herzlich willkommen
zur capt if minecraft 22 zusammen mit
gamma de guten tag herr ihre oma was
geht ab addiere man was gedacht dass das
alles weil ich habe richtig bock hier
weiterzumachen ich möchte nicht sterben
ich hab nur noch wenig herzen und
ja wir brauchen auf jeden fall auch
gleich noch was zu essen ich habe mir
gerade schon gedacht bzw
er komme sich auch wenn da oben gleich
eventuell eine kuh sollte oder irgendwas
anderes
dann kann es ja sein dass wenn das
runterfällt sind die droht deswegen
bauen wir jetzt erstmal die ganzen
passen auch mit einer spitzhacke nimm
lieber mal die kaputte noch so ein
bisschen schnell kaputt ist schon
mittlerweile leider komplett kaputt
berühmt weil zurzeit ist ich glaube ich
einmal diesen soundtrack mit der fackel
stimmt dass mutter eine gute idee solle
doch sowas komme ich wieder hier das
kann nur ein cap triathlons in zwei
minuten in achten oder so 73 sekunden
das mache ich hier auch wir haben uns
nicht gedacht dass wir eine super tolle
wendeltreppe von da oben runter bauen
allerdings geht das nicht mit diesem
sand oder können wir den sand irgendwie
verbrennen wir hier unten machen kommt
man hier vom boden aus sie arbeiten
du musst jetzt geht auch kummer so kommt
dann kann man hier schon mal hoch gehen
und danach musste ton blöcke verwenden
genau die ab hier verwende ich aber soll
wenn ich lieber für alle stolberger
verwenden dass sie glaube ich cool aus
ich mache doch später drauf machen weil
wenn ich erstmal vorankommen dass ein
wenig ja mach du mal da oben die treppe
weiter
diese folge sieht ziemlich grad nur bei
mir da könnt ihr keine sicht von gomez
sehen werdet ihr sehen wollt müsst ihr
morgen bei mir vorbeischauen genau
machen wir wieder wie beim ersten teil
alles abwechselnd mit deren dran war
nämlich schon mal so eine kleine treppe
ja wenn du mal hoch kommst wir haben
hier oben sind ja ich weiß nicht wieso
türen setzlinge in die von dem baum die
der hier wo ich gerade stehe was macht
man mit dem ich habe dinge hat auch
schon gesehen ich war gerade auch schon
ganz kurz hier oben nicht das worauf ach
ja ich weiß es nicht so sehr gut da
kriegt man aber auch nichts vermerkt hab
das einfach nur zur optik okay wir
lassen wir einfach mal stehen
mal schauen er sieht ja ganz schön
aussah er sieht auf jeden fall ein
wunderschöner so wir wollten schauen wie
es geht wie geht's weiter mit deiner
vorne und was ich gedacht hätte wollen
uns vielleicht hier hin noch unsere
baseballer können wir irgendwann den
goldenen sand hier medien ganz oben
sondern bald meinst du nicht wir wollen
das ende eine etage weiter unten machen
können wir auch nicht gedacht so
tageslicht dann wächst vielleicht später
alles bisschen schneller
ja ja aber wir können wir gerne machen
dann der dann verlegen wir alles nach
hier oben oder ich mache ich meine
vieles bei dieser karte spielt
sicherheit unterirdisch ab muss man
vorher oder wir setzen unsere bessert in
denen oder wir setzen uns unsere pace in
den raum der monumente genau das meinte
ich halt das ist halt eine etage weiter
und hier oben habe ich gerade schon
gesehen dass er dieses schwarze zeit mit
der leiter hat auch schon gesehen
ja das ist die leute die da unten auch
schon angezeigt mit hinter der tür
schätze ich jetzt mal da hat man
wahrscheinlich einen schnelleren weg
nach oben
direkt brauchst du die wendeltreppe
krawatte genau damit wir einfach hier
schnell den kopf
okay gut als er sieht nicht schön aus
ich habe ja noch zwei fackeln ist jetzt
mal ja noch nie das eigentlich genug
leute die so dass ich mich aber wirklich
die ganze zeit frage was bitteschön
erhalten wie holz das frage ich mich
dann auch vor allem nicht meine axt wir
müssen gleich mal gucken vielleicht noch
ein bisschen weiter runter also die met
ist ja doch wäre so tief dass ist gleich
der erste stein schwer tragen nur noch
wenig herzen stirbt ok humba humba humba
humba humba humba humba das erst
freigesetzt
echt lucent hat sich fragen gesagt hat
ich komme doch wie an holz und meine
güte mal redet gerade ich es über das
thema sollen wir das jetzt ersetzen
dieses glas bist du dir dabei sicher
komme warte ich muss man eben schnell
hoch kommen zu dir die wendeltreppe sich
auf jeden fall schon mal schön aus ich
habe dieses dieser kleine dieser ton ich
könnte mich da ich dann verlieben der
sieht so schön aus
auch hier sind die schönsten blöcke ich
habe sechs stück und ich gerade vor red
stage soll ich das glas jetzt abbauen
tu was du tun musst ok meine lieben
freunde komme der sichtbare halt für das
n900 ist nach oben weil ich glaube weg
nach oben erscheint ja gleich das items
oder was auch immer
monument complete oje das passiert was
passiert was ist passiert ich habe ihnen
das gehört schauen wir weiter nach oben
wo mein gott diese sicherungen einbauen
sondern das können wir aus dem sand oder
puzzle unendlich essen durch durch eine
schale müssen wir uns noch machen dann
haben wir unendlich essen dann kann
du kannst doch mit einer schale
rechtsklick auf die drauf machen heißt
shops da kein runter sie müssen wir
direkt einzuholen warte mal warte mal
warte mal aber wir haben kein holz macht
mit gold nimmt machen mit dem sand ich
habe nen bogen übrigens krass wollen wir
die andere kuh hierhin geschickt die
malereien irgendwie q/q komm schon du
dir jetzt kann auch ins durch weiße
wände mit einer wenn du mit nach metten
mit einer holzschale auf die rechtsweg
machst dann kommt ja immer kommt da
immer pilzsuppe raus die hat sind quasi
nun endlich pilzsuppe quelle von hier
aus das am besten von der seite her
schiebt sie immer noch ein bisschen dazu
der anderen ja so und jetzt so groß wie
das sticken blitz ein ohren steht das
erfolgreich sei es wird mit regen an
87 okay was ich muss nochmal hier ein
bisschen wegschubsen damit wir die ok
das ist wirklich bisschen wenig platz
hatte ich mach das mal ganz gut an ein
online eines stibitzt nein nein nein
nein coni warte
nein die alten zweite überhaupt
irgendwas oder bis einfach blind auf
beiden augen selbst komme ich hab die
wir zurückgestutzt
ok heraus die kommt er mal wieder muss
sich beeilen
was geht da kommen ganz schnell raus
ganz schnell
soll ja wo haben wir rein aber er kommt
nicht raus rein
die beiden das ist jedenfalls mal drin
bis die world border wieder zwei größer
wird aber bis dahin aber erst mal so ein
bisschen zeit denke ich mal
oder ich glaube es geht sogar schnell
weiter mit den erfolgen ich hab erst
hinten
ich habe auch ein bisschen angst ich
mache jetzt mal ganz kurz aus dem sand
noch diese absicherung hin wenn man mit
so dass auch noch ihr das wieder dieses
paintings punkt sollte hier seltsam
million noch haben wir nicht auch schon
anderen ton ich habe auch noch drei
orange habe ich auch ich hab davon sechs
und ich hab auch gebrannter ton also
irgendwie ohne farbe oder so also der
heißt nur gebrannter ton und ich finde
spinne ich freue mich weiter nach unten
kommen darunter ich komm rat noch und
ich hab aber ein holzschwert mich jetzt
yellowstone was ist das blue state und
ich habe orange ja ich habe angst
okay wir brauchen als nächstes gelb und
blau weil dann gibt's ja diese momente
du kannst dir mal her ich habe aufgabe
für dich du kannst ja die werkbank und
die tron auf oben bringen
die werkbank und die truhe ja unser live
wasser schwimmt wenn ich mache das eben
schon okay top das ok die ganze sache
die natur sind klopp mir jetzt mal ganz
kurz raus bis sogar weg hier unten sind
auch schon wieder monster komplett
verbockt solcher weil es jetzt konnte
die werkbank gelber gelber ton wer so
geil o2 krippe eine späte alter jedes
amt er wird einfach so geil aus dem mit
diesem ton
ich liebe diesen ton ich auch ich auch
ich bin gerade etwas angespannt ich
nehme einfach jetzt auch mal den ganzen
ton beck und packt jetzt einfach mal so
ein partner sachen da kommt jetzt mal
dies hin
overmeyer alter was machst du da was auf
alles gut doch mal richtig gut aufpassen
ok cribari sind vier körper
so verlagert wir wollen dann unsere
basin dem ruhm auf monuments machen
richtig genau ja okay dann setze ich
dann die sachen mal hin ich mache das
einfach hier irgendwo wo es ganz schön
aussieht
ja und dann kommt jemand der crafting
table hin so oder packt jetzt erst mal
ein paar sachen rein
wir haben gebranntem ton orangen ton
roten wenn ich kinder lockern
wir brauchen yellow und blue wenn du
irgendwo was gelbes oder was blaues ich
kommen zu dir ja die tür da können wir
auch noch nicht durch
ein russischer alles auch schon ist
alles super wartet wo ist noch mal der
eingang bevor wir uns nicht hier na ja
hier kann mir noch mehr fackeln ich
hatte nur eine
ich weiß noch wo er habe ich die
bekommen von mir oben hoch bleiben hat
die kam aus dem blue monster wann welche
hingesetzt
ja okay hier ist keys ich sehe wenn ich
durch die world water gucke geht die
höhe da hinten schon krass weiter
davon ist auch noch leben in der ferne
erleben brauchen wir auch ehrlich ja
aber erwischt kann auch sein dass wir
einfach wie ich sehe da hinten links
auch ne kiste noch aber ich weiß sie ist
da ganz hinten unten in der höhle da ja
da müssen wir auch noch später hin also
oben habe ich auch schon so ein paar
gesehen
wir müssen jetzt halt auch immer immer
oben und unten schauen gegen ihn wegen
den ganzen christen wollen wir die kohle
für wasser wie kohle ausgeben was können
wir denn da machen wir haben erstmal
genug dass wir uns einen ofen machen
können er schlug auf hilfe warten
bleibt nun mal ganz kurz hier unten wie
bist du denn hier untergegangen übrigens
ihr hier lang als okay ich gehe mal ganz
kurz wieder nach oben
wir brauchen holz das also woher
bekommen wir holz komme ja
bei der humba humba humba humba humba
humba
warum so was hast du gemacht heisst
angelegenheiten mit dem schlucker wieder
richtig gefällt schon überlegt was
können wir denn jetzt mit einem ofen
machen sondern sind alle sachen guckt
man die kiste ist und alle sachen die
wir haben wirklich
achtung jetzt kommt zack zack zack zack
zack zack zack zack und noch mehr frohes
neues okay wir können auf jeden fall
erstmal nicht die kohle verbraten nicht
für das eisen weil ein eisen bringen uns
erst mal nichts
wir haben 16 ton aus diesem kleinen
daraus können wir uns diese blöcke
machen oder ja hier mit fünf töpfe
einfach fünf tonnen
ich packe den ton nach unten in die
kiste okay dann haben wir noch orangenen
ton roten ton und gebranntem ton ja was
da jetzt so wirklich was von brink weiß
jetzt gar nicht weil wir brauchen uns
blauen ton euro yello also blauen und
gelben ton brauchen wir hier nur um das
nächste mal einen moment zu erreichen
und ich brauche auf jeden fall noch was
zu fressen ich auch heißt wir brauchen
holz um uns eine schale zu machen
wir haben doch hier 16 schüsseln wie sie
sagten nichts da liegen 60 schüssel in
der kiste
warum hast du nichts gesagt hahaha okay
ich habe ganz gespannt ist es nicht die
kühe sind noch da ich mach erst mal die
ganzen schüsseln voll mit suppen geil
haben 16 suppen ja ich geb dir mal macht
123456 das sowie mit den hühnchen
das ist doch mal der hammer leider kann
man die nicht decken das wird ja das ist
das raum aber du kannst du auch volle
suppen schalen ich stecke da fließt dann
alle 300 natürlich da aber die geben
auch richtig viele mal diese suppen
schalen und wir können es einfach
richtig viel davon holen aber auch
vielschreiber schon mal die truhe com
teil einen schiefen oder eine tief mit
ok kommen wir gucken jetzt mal ganz kurz
nach erfolge
bauer eine felljacke ob machen diesen
wir wir könnten die feld hacke machen
wir haben es mehr ist da haben wir kein
holz mehr
das ging los mit invent hast du noch in
den balken nehmen gar nicht schade
schade ich schaue mir noch weiter eben
push ups versammle etwas leder
nee das geht nicht da auf jeden fall
keine das geht leider auch gar nicht
töten ein skelett mit einem pfeil aus
einer entfernung ja das machen wir
gleich und da hab ich mir gedacht dass
wir das so machen dass das skelett das
kann auch einfach aus und stehen bei
feile kann man durch die wakeboarder
durchschießen und da ich den tipp think
outside the box
das ist aus portal dieses zitat glaube
ich in lodz apple macht mir ganz am ende
das sparen sparen das ganze gold ok
alles gold fall sparen
fang und berater einen fisch schmilzt
eisenerz im ofen das können wir machen
wir das machen dann machen dafür
brauchen wir auch noch einen holz glaube
ich und werden in der nächsten folge
machen wir heute noch das machen jetzt
noch schnell die folge ist noch nicht so
dann okay auf geht's ist drin
okay wir können uns genau was hast du
denn reingepackt kohle
wieso denn kohle du solltest ein holz
rheinpark kohle werden unten auch noch
cool okay gut so ok humba humba humba
humba humba humba
und jetzt haben wir mich oben die kiste
geöffnet ok und krawatte das macht mir
nämlich im gomez folge da werden wir die
kiste morgen öffnet heißt ihr müsst
jetzt noch eine nacht drüber schlafen
und dann werden wir in gómez folge
morgen die kiste öffnen
ich kenne ja schonmal rate deckt
vertritt ist wahrscheinlich wissen schon
voll viele rallye die mir selber
gespielt haben jetzt schon was geiles
und haben wir neue moment nehmen wir
müssen nicht dass man die anderen
irgendwie fertig kriegen denkt ich
obwohl hier noch kommen erzählte dass
laien staind was es hier
yello light gray da weiß ich nicht jetzt
sorgen war angesagt noch angezeigt
hier steht green steht er nicht irgendwo
in magenta team orange nämlich richtig
für uns aber wir haben auf jeden fall
genug zu fressen
ich würde auf jeden fall nicht sagen
dass wir immer die ganzen pilzsuppe
mitten im sondern jeder nur für sich
immer mitnimmt und das parken in die
kiste damit wir in zukunft auch pilz
open haben bald mit vier bisher schon
komplett voll
stimmt schon deswegen freunde ich würde
sagen wenn es euch gefallen da zeigt es
mit einem markt wie wir haben richtig
viel geschafft haben die basic regel
werden die ersten momente eröffnet man
richtig coole folge morgen öffnen wie
bei gome die dritte kiste glaub ich
mittlerweile die uns freigesetzt wird
und dann kümmern wir uns wieder um die
momentan das wird richtig geil und bis
morgen